اعلن وزير الدفاع الروسي السي شيجو ان
الوضع الاكثر
توترا يتشكل على محور زبروجيا حيث دفعت
اوكرانيا
باحتياطي جي وقال شاجو ان خسائر القوات
الاوكرانيه خلال شهر واحد فقط بلغت اكثر
من 66 الف شخص مشيرا الى ان الخسائر
الماديه هي ايضا كبيره اذا دمر اكثر من 1
مسيره خلال الفتره
نفسها
القوات الروسيه بتسديدها ضربات عاليه
الدقه تستمر في تدمير البنيه التحتيه
العسكريه الاوكرانيه الوضع الاكثر توترا
تشكل في محور زبروجيا حيث دفع العدو الى
المعركه بالويه من الاحتياط الاستراتيجي
تم تدريب جنودها باشراف مدربين غربيين منذ
بدايه ما يسمى بالهجوم المضاد تجاوزت
خسائر العدو 66 الف شخص و
7600 اله عسكريه وقطعه سلاح كما استطاعت
وحدات القتال الروسيه من خلال عملياتها
المدروسه ان تسقط
159 صاروخا من طراز هاي مارس واكثر من الف
مسيره في شهر واحد